Thank you all for being here.
My name is Kelly.
I teach statistics
and data science.
And on this first slide, you
are seeing the beautiful city
of Barcelona, Spain.
And I put that up there
because a week from today,
I will hopefully be there
to meet my boyfriend's
parents for the first time.
He is fully Spanish.
I very wisely took
10 years of French,
so I don't really
speak Spanish and I
have been practicing a bit.
And so that has
gotten me thinking
a little about translating
between ordinary languages
and translating between
programming languages.
And so this whole
hook was, of course,
just an excuse for me to
be like, hey, everyone,
I have a boyfriend.
That's him.
And so, you know, I've been
listening to this podcast that
teaches Spanish, and
there was this phrase
that they were teaching
that kind of struck me.
And it looked like this
"Me gusta ver a mis amigos".
Sorry for the pronunciation.
And that there are these amigos
was the point of the episode.
It's kind of a
weird construction
for what they're trying to say
is "I like to see my friends".
But of course, if you were
to translate, you know,
word for word or
literally to english,
we would be saying
"it is pleasing
to me to see to my friends",
which of course, is not
a thing that we say in English.
And so this got me thinking
about that idea of a 1-to-1
direct translation and
how that's not really
how languages actually work.
So can we apply
this sort of theory
of language learning to
programming languages instead?
So I'd like to start
off with a pop quiz.
It's the first talk
of this year's rstudio::conf
besides the keynote.
And I'm hitting you with a quiz.
Sorry not sorry.
Here is your pop quiz.
Oops I don't know why
that's not showing you
my pop quiz in words.
This code right here.
Is the object
returned by that code
going to be two
dimensional, like a matrix
or a dataframe, or something
with rows and columns?
Or is it going to
be one dimensional,
like a vector or an array?
Who's going to say
one dimensional?
two dimensional?
Could I see you
people who raised
your hands for two dimensional
after seeing the one
dimensional?
The answer, as you might expect,
is it's a trick question.
As we know, posit is no
longer an R only company.
In R, this exact
code right here,
taking a column of
the penguin's data set
is going to be one
dimensional, right?
That's yanking out
a column. In Python,
that thing is two dimensional.
That is a dataframe
with one column.
So this is an example
of there is not
a direct translation between
these two rather similar,
rather close languages.
That exact code will
run in both languages
and it will produce a
different structure of results.
So what motivated this?
There's a class that I teach
every year at Cal Poly.
It's called
statistical learning,
and we're kind of upgrading it
to Statistical Learning with R,
but then I've added
in the Python,
so this class is kind
of upper level class.
It's mostly but not
entirely stat majors
in their final years of
their undergrad degree.
There's no computing
prerequisite.
I think going to change that.
Turning this off because
I'm getting echo there.
There's no computing
prerequisite.
So any R or Python
that I use, I have
to kind of spoon
feed a little bit.
Back when this class
was first offered in 2020,
I didn't teach it.
It was kind of a
hodgepodge, as many of us
have done with modeling.
It was using caret and base R,
and tidyverse for the data
wrangling, and just kind
of all over the place.
So when I took it over, I
changed it to tidymodels,
and that was really fun.
Like tindmodels is
kind of new and it made
it so much easier to teach it.
I could go on, but that's
not the point of this talk.
And then this year,
for some reason,
instead of doing the
smart thing and just
reusing my materials with little
tweaks that had gone very well,
I decided to translate
everything also
into scikitlearn in Python.
So I want to tell you
what this talk isn't.
I am not encouraging
you to do this.
This is extra work for
me without a huge amount
of benefit in the class.
I am not trying to encourage
you to teach a bilingual class,
although if you're
interested, I would
love to talk to you about it.
I did it kind of because there's
sort of these two funnels
into this course.
And one side of that funnel
is the computer science,
data science minors.
I wanted it to be accessible.
I want it to fit in
our eventual data
science bachelor's program.
And I really wanted to practice.
And, you know, it's one of
those things where, like, you
commit when you're
feeling enthusiastic
and then you're
forced into it, right?
So I wanted to
practice python, I
wanted to pick up Quarto,
which is nice for using both.
So that's why I did it.
So I'm not telling you to do it.
I did it for fun.
Fun, so that's not the
point of this talk.
So what is the
point of this talk?
What I want to talk
to you about is
what I learned from watching
the students learn differently
from these two languages,
like the two cohorts who
chose are versus Python.
And specifically
thinking about how
these different implementations,
not just across languages
but maybe even across
packages, is going to impact
understanding for these users.
And specifically, I know
most people in this room,
maybe because of the
track, might be educators,
but I kind of have
split this out
into advice for
developers or creators,
for users of the tools,
and then, of course, most
importantly, for educators.
One step behind.
There we go.
So let's dive in.
So thinking about how
you learn a new language
or how you translate
between languages
and now I'm thinking back
to Spanish and French.
Probably the first thing that
comes to mind is that's hard.
That was in my first
example is grammar
and specifically like
sentence structure.
Like why do these same words
go in a totally different order
in different languages?
And so how I might
kind of parallel
that in programming
languages is this idea
of what's the structure
of your analysis.
Like you have to do these
multiple steps to do
an analysis, but in
different implementations,
those steps might happen
at different times.
So here's what I mean.
Here's two code chunks.
The top one is
scikitlearn / Python.
The bottom one down there is
tidymodels / R, of course.
And my question to you is,
when in these two chunks
do we decide which
predictors are
going to go into our models?
It's just the linear model
with a couple of predictors.
And that's happening right here.
So it feels kind of the same
in both languages right now,
right at the moment where you
are fitting the data after you
specified your
model, that's when
you're declaring which variables
are part of this model.
But then you start thinking
about preprocessing.
So here's some Python
code that includes
a step where we are
log transforming both
of our quantitative predictors.
And so we added some
stuff to the process.
But you can see in Python,
the preprocessing decision
happens early, and
then the decision
about which predictors
we're actually doing
that to happens at the fit step.
But in tidymodels here,
we now
have this idea of
recipes. this just
right?
So the recipe then
contains both the decision
about your predictors
and the decision
about how you are going
to transform them.
And even though
it's all together,
it's actually in
the opposite order.
You choose your predictors
and then your transformations.
And so this is
slightly different.
And I'm not saying it's wrong.
Like I don't think that either
one is necessarily wrong,
but having different approaches
is going to have consequences.
And so here's what
happened with my students,
like the ones that were using
tidymodels kind of focused
really on feature selection.
They really focused
on, which predictors
are going to be in my model.
And then once they decided
that they were like, yeah,
maybe we could log
transform them.
And the ones who use scikit
learn really focused on how
do we adjust the data?
They kind of thought
of this transformation
as part of the data
cleaning, and they
did that first, and then allowed
some predictors or others
to be in their model.
So what's the takeaway
from that observation?
While developers,
I just want you
to be aware of how
your API design is
going to influence
how people think
about the actual concepts.
This is not a separate thing.
And then.
I want, when possible,
if you can be kind
of agnostic, if you
can allow, like I'm thinking of
how the recipes and the model
specification in
tidymodels, it
doesn't really matter which
order you declare them.
They're sort of
separate entities
that you put together later.
I think that's a really good
design choice, personally.
And then my last
suggestion is just
keeping kind of related
decisions together.
Like I don't necessarily
think I scikitlearn is wrong,
but I don't like this thing that
you go through the whole setup.
And then you specify
your predictors.
And of course you
could like insert steps
where you make another
dataframe to solve for that.
But, the way that it's
sort of naturally set up
doesn't keep those
decisions together.
My advice for users here.
Try to match your code
flow with your narrative
where you have choices.
If you are thinking through
a problem in a certain way,
try to match your code.
And then, of course,
intersperse your code with text.
This is why that discussion and
documentation is so important.
If you're doing two
parallel analyses
in different
languages, but you have
to kind of shuffle
parts of it, then
you are going to
need that discussion
text to help match those up.
You know, and then
as much as you
can kind of compartmentalize,
make your steps modular.
Here's where we
choose the model.
Here's where we choose
the predictors that
also kind of lets you
swap between languages.
And then my advice for
educators here, enforce
a workflow on your students
that matches the way
that you teach it.
Two clicks.
Break your analysis up.
Same idea as the practitioners.
If you are isolating
these decisions,
then when they see them
in different orders,
they recognize that decision.
And then really push
students to document,
to write what they're doing,
to state their decisions
outside the context of the code.
All right.
Next thing that I find
difficult in learning languages
is false friends or foes of me.
When I learned French words
that sound really similar.
And have different meanings.
So if I come up to you later in
this conference and I say this.
You're probably going to
make that face if you are not
a Spanish speaker.
But it turns out I have
learned that this just
means I have a cold.
I'm kind of congested.
It doesn't mean what
you might think.
Or another one.
If you come up to me and you
say your talk was quite good,
I'm going to be really
happy unless I find out
that you are from the UK.
We're quite means
like me, you know.
So this word quite in English
does not mean the same thing
in every culture.
And so what does this
look like in code?
What it looks like to me is
similar functions or arguments
that behave differently.
So by way of example, I want
to talk a little about support
vector machines.
Not going to teach you
support vector machines.
I'm going to do
this really quick.
We are trying to find a line
to separate these two classes.
We want that line
to push the classes
apart as much as possible.
So we want those dotted lines to
be as far from the solid line.
But as we push
the classes apart,
we end up with on
the right hand side
those points that
are misclassified
or that kind of fall
inside that margin.
So when we fit a
support vector machine,
we're trying to minimize
that misclassification,
maximize that margin.
This is the push and pull.
And so as you would hope in the
implementation and tidymodels,
there is indeed a parameter
that is the cost of having
points fall inside of a margin.
And in scikitlearn as you
would hope there is a parameter
C that has to do with
the cost of points
falling in the margin.
But let's look at those
a little more closely.
tidymodels version is the
cost of predicting wrong,
so the cost of a sample
landing in the margin
or on the wrong side.
In scikitlearn I could learn.
notice that it says, see, the
strength of the regularization
is inversely proportional to
see the regularization being
that penalized for
misclassification.
So these work opposite.
They're capturing
the same thing.
They're capturing the same idea.
Again, neither is wrong.
But when my students sitting
next to each other using
different languages tried the
same values for cost and for
see because they were
trying to tune their model,
they got different results and
that was very confusing to them
and to me for quite some time.
And so what happens here is that
then the students, of course,
conceptualize that
penalty differently.
So the tidymodels
students are conceptualizing it
as a penalty on
misclassification,
whereas the psychic students
are conceptualizing it
as like a balancing parameter,
a regularization parameter.
How much do we
balance the margin,
the desire for a wide margin
with the desire for less points
inside that margin?
So it's, you know, again, not
wrong leads to different ideas.
And so what I would remind
everyone to do is, you know,
be explicit if you're
designing tools.
I think cost of
misclassification
helped me track down
what was going on.
I think amount of regularization
did not because regularization
is a little more general.
And then, you
know, I don't think
I'm not asking for consistency
in parameterization.
I'm not asking that you make
sure everything's the same.
I'm asking you be upfront
because it's not possible
that everything's the
same, and people like me
need to be able to track
down what the difference is.
My advice for educators
and practitioners,
state everything in words.
Say things like when
the cost is higher,
we expect less
misclassification and the cost
of that is a smaller
margin, like if you say that
out loud, than you are
understanding that parameter.
And then as always,
translate these choices
to non-code language.
Term three moving
swiftly along, I think.
But learning language is slang.
Terms become hard.
My favorite slang term
in English is stan.
You know this phrase
stan, to stan something,
or to be a stan.
It means you're
like our big fan.
Basically, we're all
stands of are in here.
How many of where it came from?
So this came from a
music video and song
by Eminem about a very obsessed
fan whose name was literally
Stan like Stanley.
And somehow over
the years, this word
evolved to mean
something much broader
and something that is used know.
And people don't
even remember that it
came from a person's name.
And so I think the
equivalent of slang in code
is maybe these helper
wrapper functions that
contain a whole lot of meaning,
like way more than what
that one word might suggest.
And when I see this in my
class is in tuning parameters.
So when you tune, and we're
sticking here with those vector
machines, when
you tune, you need
to decide which values
you're going to try.
Right and in both Python
on top and R on the bottom,
you can just sort
of manually create
kind of that list
of different values
that we're going to
try for our model.
But tidy models also comes
with the shortcut where
we can access built in
functions with the names
of the parameters, and
it will automatically
choose values for you that
it thinks are reasonable.
And like, I love this.
I'm not saying this is bad.
Like, I would much
rather have Max Kugn
decide which values I'm
tuning than me decide.
That's great.
Right I don't know why.
Like 0.0009 and 32 are better
choices than ten, 20, 30.
But I assume max does.
Or whoever wrote this
part of tidymodels.
I'm fine with it.
But again, this was my
biggest shock in the class.
The Python students
picked it up better,
like everyone understood
tuning the first time
that I taught it.
And then nine weeks of
hands on activities later.
If you ask the
students about tuning,
they went into detail
on the functions.
And if you ask the Python
students, they got the concept.
We just try a bunch of different
values and see what sticks.
And so that was
surprising to me.
And so I don't
really have advice
like shortcut
functions are great.
I don't think they
should change.
I'm not saying that.
I do think, again that
translating to English
is a good thing, but most
importantly for educators,
(not clicking for me)
There we go, for educators.
Think about if you're
using a wrapper function,
basically assume that
what you're doing
is glossing over that concept.
So that's OK like I
do this with step k,
I don't teach all of
pKa necessarily when
I'm pre-processing, but
avoid shortcut functions
on things that are actually
learning goals in your class.
OK I got 2 minutes.
I think the next one
I will do quickly.
So the last challenge
I want to point out
is like meaning that isn't
in words, that's in gestures
and in the movie Encanto we
have it's not moving this moment
where she points with her lips.
And I've learned
that this is like
a super cool cultural
thing in Colombia
that we don't do in the US.
Is pointing with your lips.
So here's your pop quiz
and the code context.
And I won't make you vote
because I'm low on time.
(How is the question
is not showing?)
How does the k-means function
choose initial clusters?
If you don't know
k-means ignore it.
I asked this on Twitter.
This is what people said.
This is what I would have
said before I dug into this.
And it is not correct.
So here is how I used
to teach k-means.
Choose your initial
centroid by choosing
three random observations.
Assign all the points
to the nearest centroid,
re-compute the centroid
of each cluster,
keep going until
you have clusters.
I've taught it
that way for years.
It turns out that
nothing about that
is correct about how k-means
actually works.
I mean, it can set it to be.
But that is not the
default in this function.
The default in this
function, although it
says that it will choose three
initial observations down
there, that method
Hartigan-Wong,
default method. Hartigan-Wang
neither initializes that
way, nor does it even
update in the same way
as the other methods.
So everything I've just
told you is not the default.
In scikitlearn they're
a little more upfront.
But now this initialization k
plus plus, that's different.
At least they kind
of explain it,
but they just say it's smart.
And then you can think about
using different functions in R
that one contains k plus plus
k plus plus is not an option
to the base k means function.
But now we don't have an
option to choose your iteration
process.
So there is literally
no way to guarantee,
at least with these
two implementations,
that the R and the
Python output matches.
And so what was the result?
Just frustration.
Just you cannot make that
output be the same with
the implementations people use.
And so I think
these get repeated.
I'm going to skip to kind
of my final takeaways
because they contain those ones.
So recap.
We have these challenges.
And these challenges that
you see in language also
appear in coding.
So the developers in the
room, what I want you to do,
don't assume that the
choice of the parameter name
tells people what
that parameter does.
Don't assume that
these default choices
are the obvious choices.
They're not universal.
You have to document them.
And the order that we code
is the order that we think.
For practitioners
again, translation
is not going to be a
direct word for word.
Please discuss what
you're deciding.
Please document.
Please use text.
And for educators, really
what you want to do
is force your students to be
explicit about every decision.
So thank you for
sticking with me.
The slides are on line.
Oh, there we go.
Please find me.
Please talk to me.
I'm going to have to get
to the other talk.